we're going to look at King and pawn end
games because I like king upon and game
each one has a different theme and then
after we look at some made-up positions
that I made up that were made up before
I made them up as I stole them then
we'll look at some games from actual
play and see if we can play the games
better now that we know the ideas this
is the most the most this is the least
famous theme and all of King and pawn
end games does anybody know the theme to
win this endgame it has a name anyone
know Colin voters opposition is a
partial credit partial but no credit
this is actually triangulation which
doesn't happen very often if you play
normally king e5 as a normal move
because no other move and if you just
play normally then you will still Nate
your opponent stalemate and if the age
pawns weren't on the board this would be
a draw rather easy drop but because of
triangulation we can create a Suk's long
position so after king e5 King f8 black
is in Zuke's long although it's not his
move so he's done in zoogs Wong so what
White has to do is make it blacks move
so if black played king f7 in this
position white would play king f5 and
win because this King would go to g6 and
if black played King e8 white would play
King e6 and have the opposition so the
way for whites win is to lose a tempo by
moving his King backwards you can go to
e4 or f4 ephors easier for me because
it's straight back and if King f7 for
example then King f5 is an easy one
because the next move is king g6
and will be to puns ahead okay so black
plays king e8 and once again white hangs
around with king f4 he's waiting for
black to play King f8 again if King f7
we play King f5 and King g6 so King f8
and now we play King e5 and if you can
remember one minute ago we have this
position but there was White's move and
now it's blacks move and the last three
moves white created a triangle sort of
by playing to the same color to the same
color black black and black had to
change color every move so now it's
blacks move
if black goes here white easily wins by
taking this pawn and there is a trick
though that black can play which will
work on some people in the camp most
people not in this class but and that's
if King e8 we get the opposition and
everybody's happy and if you're not
paying attention and you promote to
Queen that would be stalemate and you
don't want it stalemate so that would be
a mistake what's the best move for white
in this position because promoting to a
queen would be stalemate promote to a
knight would win but that would be quite
difficult although not too difficult but
more difficult than other moves
according to night winds pointing to a
rook wins promoting to a bishop wins the
quickest win is to not promote to wait a
move so you can promote with check by
playing King to f6 black has to go here
and then we can make a queen ray and
this triangulation is the only way to
win you have to play King e5 and then go
back with your king lose a tempo and
make this position with black to move
and well triangulation doesn't happen
very often but Zuke's wong happens a lot
where and we'll see that in later
examples today where if it's your move
you're not winning and if it's your
opponent's move now you're winning and
in the open
a middle game there's about a zero
percent chance of that and King upon
endings it's about 25% that happens
because in some positions you have the
perfect position so you don't want to
move that's the starting position here
both sides have a perfect position if
black is forced to move White's King
walks in and if White's forced to move
which is then black and chill out but
luckily white can lose a tempo and then
it's blacks turn to move and black loses
that might be one of the harder ones for
this class okay now we can extrapolate
from what we've learned and make up
puzzles however this puzzle was not made
up this was a game that I saw control
hoo-yeah control to it okay so this is a
game that I saw in the 2000
2008 US Women's Championship in Tulsa
Oklahoma Tulsa Oklahoma it sounds like I
made it up but it's true
and the player with the white pieces was
the mongolian player who we called chimi
because we can't say her name but it's
actually betcha meg to Shin Tubbs so I
can say it it's funny ha Mongolian
player playing the US Women's
Championship when are you gonna do she
played for the u.s. at the time she's
moved back to Mongolia and she plays
from Mongolia now black is the formal
Ukranian player well they're not really
but she's from the Ukraine therefore
she's in the US Women's Championship
every year and there's several women I
could say whose name now but this is
Irina zanuck Irina crush also could have
filled in for that but Irina crush
action had something else to do with
this game she was the one who showed the
players how to play better when it ended
she was watching well if we try to win
the same way notice how these two pawns
were added although Julio didn't see the
last problems he's like what you're
talking about but but yeah these two
puns weren't here in the last problem in
the last problem
white would triangulate and then white
would play king f4 here which is
slightly illegal so the triangulation of
work the player with the white pieces
they knew about triangulation and they
knew they couldn't triangulate so they
both moved around a lot forever and
agreed to a draw one one kind of a draw
would be the brute-force method and now
black plays G for white takes and it's
stalemate or white could not take and
lose which is even worse than black
Queens so this is a draw and what ended
up happening was white moves her King
around a lot and black would her King
around a lot they agreed to a draw but
when the game ended there was a big
fight between Bohr's goal ko and Irina
crush to see who could run up to the
board faster to show them the win they
missed and although obviously black
didn't miss a win white did and the
player with black was seeing a looking
board like obviously this is a draw and
moving quickly and she also thought this
was a draw but Goku and crush explained
in this position sees me ah it was goko
I think he pushed her down kids are a
couple times - yeah at the same time
they're like here ah okay so in this
position white has a simple winning move
which neither player saw well I guess
it's not simple because either player
slot and after this move there's no
doubt that White's winning and Gwen
Stefani agreed
nobody gets the no doubt choke somebody
at home got it right then what yeah I
said there was no doubt about who would
win this position thank you I'll be here
all night hmm
anyone anyone they went home or call in
for the future nobody ever calls it for
the future movies they do it like half
the time on our show never yeah yeah all
right we'll let you work on that so I'm
going to show you a problem later that
has the same theme and you'll solve that
because you saw this one now they won't
okay so the winning move is f7 giving
the pawn away because we're not trying
to stick we're not trying to Queen that
pawn we're trying to move our King into
the position and take blacks pawns black
captures and white plays King f5 this is
your chance opposition right and now
while whites going to play here and take
two pawns so black doesn't want that to
happen so black plays King g7 and I mean
White's King is going to walk in there's
nothing black can do just walks right in
and takes all the pawns see in this
position if white had an F pawn which he
doesn't or she doesn't this is to be the
stalemate trick again we're black just
plays g4 and it's gonna be stalemate but
giving away the plot means there's no
stalemates so White's King can rock
right in why white never thought of the
move f7 because that looks crazy why
would you give you a pawn away well you
give it away so the White King could
walk in and take the black pawns but
white never thought of that and white
wins easily white just takes both ones
but didn't happen so I didn't win it was
a draw unfortunate oh look at this I am
okay now here white is in trouble so
this way you people feel more at home
you know while you're getting crushed
right yeah okay
Isaac's like I've won every game this
week we're talking about okay uh well
White's King is it as good as blacks
King and whites trying to Queen and
blacks trying to Queen but more
importantly blacks taking the pawn and
white is not in time to defend the pawn
so for example if white plays King c2
black plays King d4 King d3 although not
legal would I probably seen it all week
at the camp unfortunate okay and black
wins the pawn now in these kinds of
positions if you're wondering is it a
win or a draw when the King is two
squares in front of the pawn which it is
here it's always a win when it's right
in front of the pawn it depends whose
move it is okay well here the King is
two squares in front of the pond so does
it defend his move it is it's just a win
for black so black is going to win the
pawn and white has to realize that and
white wants to lose the pawn in the most
well the best way for him and if blacks
king wants to be really far in front of
the pawn you either have to make blacks
King go backwards or do what else much
louder make the pawn go forward so the
drawing move is making the pawn go
forward what's that you should sit
closer then I can't see either but I you
know that doesn't stop me
I play blindfold on e5 right good for
not seeing okay you'll play you all for
money after the class and for the future
it's hard to understand okay
all of a sudden he's ready to realize it
now black has to take now it's hard for
the Kings to get in front of the pawn
because the the plum moved up a lot now
a typical player would play king c2 and
lose because Isaac would
opposition with what move well what
would black do to get the opposition
here we'll get to that later
King c4 Kings are opposing and now
whichever way white goes let's say this
way black goes the other way and black
is winning because black will make a
queen making a queen is good you're
taking notes and these are the next four
moves but as Isaac also pointed out King
c2 is not a good move but I can get
what's called the disc like black and
white can get what's called the distant
opposition with what move king c1 and
now he's ready for any move that black
makes he could also move his king I'll
give King here he can get the opposition
and black can't go forward because he's
opposing Kings and the black won't be
able to move his king for it so it'll be
a drawn position however black does have
one more try hoping that white blunders
black and play King here and once again
white only has one drawing move and once
again it's the distant opposition same
as the last move King to d1 and in fact
if I move like King to d2 then black
wins with what move getting the
opposition ray King to d4 and now white
has to move away and lose so this is the
distant opposition and you're ready for
your opponent to move if king D for
candy two opposing kings and if king e4
then King e2 also with the draw and I
actually seen these kind of end games in
real tournaments the person with white
is 1300 1400 and every move is a draw
and they're drawing and they're drawing
and then at some point they after 2030
moves they make a mistake and they lose
I see it all the time like in this
position black has four legal moves but
black/white has too much to drink today
I think what's in this white ass for
legal moves but only one of them drawers
that's not a good percentage
what's the drawing move kingi one a lot
of lower ranked players would play King
F wine because you know the Kings are
sort of opposing but then King f3 and
black wins pray for black he wins but
okay what's proper play King e one and
it's a draw and we can show the final
stalemate and why can't move such
stalemate so that was called distant
opposition there's a puzzle I show most
of my students this position is very
tricky see it's not the advanced class
in your media class so in this puzzle
which isn't really chess puzzle but it's
good for your chest you're trying to get
your king of the back row so if white
gets his King to the back row he wins
if black stops him then he wins and if
you know just an opposition that you can
play correctly if you don then again so
this is actually winning for white if Y
could play king a6 here he would win
because he'd have the opposition King a4
is the distant opposition and King a2 is
the super distant opposition these moves
don't win you can't get to the back rub
but this moves you can because no matter
what black does I don't know it's a here
then we have this opposition where we
every every other square same color and
we can go here this is actually the best
move what doesn't matter okay White's
white gets to the back row but if white
makes a mistake on the first to move and
plays let's say King b1 or King bee to
black to play has one move that stops
the King from getting to the back row if
you do the distant opposition trick
you'll figure it out
so King b4 is the opposition right King
b6 is so what else is right King b8 and
the king can get to the back row because
the black king is stopping him and this
would go on forever which is not quite
so interesting so that's a distant
opposition problem where you can sort of
see this is the opposition this is the
opposition so is this yeah intermediate
there we go control to my favorite
control okay now we're going to vote
it's White's turn to move and if you
vote for black I'll take white if you
vote for white I'll take black so you're
in trouble either way you can vote white
wins with white supply you can vote
black can draw or you can invoke you
canon that's the other way to vote they
forgot these elections from ten years
ago
who says White's winning who says black
can draw who says Buchanan now more
votes than draw it's more likely if you
cannons the president and this is a draw
that's correct yeah this is a win white
just moves his king up as fast as
possible king d2 or King f2 would win
King up either way wins and now we're
two squares in front of the pond so we
win yay and then we go to the side like
this and you always want to move your
king up if possible
man this is a position that could happen
what should white play in this position
King to e6 right and then somewhere and
then a we Queen so when your King gets
two squares in front of your pawn your
gold if you figured it out beforehand
even before the lecture and your
Feingold hmm what's happen
Oh bless you that's nothing to sneeze it
that's an important puzzle ah control -
okay this is a famous breakthrough
problem which you're all familiar with
except for those of you that are not
familiar with it right then see he's
familiar with it he says that all of it
makes it look smart
so three pawns against three normally
that would be a draw but more important
than pawns are promoting your pawns to
Queens and here why can break through
the three black pawns and promote to a
queen as long as it's White's move if
it's black smooth black can actually
prevent it
so what move can white make to win and
Queen one of his pawns let them think a
little bit
anyone well kings you for actually might
win probably not if you break through
later can take carry the one
yeah that's not well that's not in the
spirit of what we want to do
kingi for might win if you break through
the next move I'll play King g6 then you
better break through how can the white
spawns break through the black pawns now
you could say look that way and then go
through you know like there's a squirrel
what's that
who said it'd be six right now White has
two threats so black has to capture the
B six point if black captures with a C
pawn then this pawn is ready to go but
this pawn is in his way so we play a six
eight eight and then c6 c7 c8 with
advantage if you take with the a pawn
now what is what you do
louder if you want to teach this class
one day you gotta what's at C six right
takes and then a six now having seen
that if you were black how would you
prevent white from doing that if it was
black still move so let's go here a now
it's blacks turn to move how can black
prevent white from doing all that mean
stuff making a queen
yes any pawn move would you'd be wrong
two out of three times
but meatloaf would say that's okay
because no two out of three ampad a six
and c6 both lose but B six would draw
why does a six lose I'm glad you asked a
six losses - what move White's a play
and win you guys are quiet right no
here's a lot at one of these c6 and why
it's going to make at least one Queen
maybe two queens yeah two queens if you
want yeah and c6 is the same we play a
six and we crash through and I'm sure
you were watching the World Cup today
and I'm sure you know what I'm talking
about that is funny
right now there's a tournament going on
called the World Cup with lots of prize
money something like a million dollars
plus tax and it's a knockout tournament
and in one of the matches today one of
the guys was losing and then he got like
a hundred pass pawn so he won computer
said no problem but the guy playing
didn't know how to stop the pass plan so
they Queen that's the guy picked to win
the tournament so I'm glad he won it's
not gonna win the tournament but I'm
picking him to win through however b6
does stop the pawns and there's no break
through for white whichever way white
captures if he captures black will
capture the same way notice capturing
the other way that's not not so good and
white would queen
so b6 is a draw off your black b6 is a
win if you're white so that's the key
the key idea breaking through and
there's a lot of end games where you'll
see strong players sacrifice a pawn or a
nine or a rook so they can promote upon
and get a queen that's worth more than
the sacrificed material
this is quite simple and most of my
students rated over 1300 solve it pretty
quickly however I had a student come
over rated 2200 who never had formal
chest training he didn't know anything
that's why he was 2,200 and I showed him
this and we looked at it for about five
minutes and he gave up and I another
friend who was 2,300 who was laughing at
him till he had a good time everybody
had fun this is why it's a play and win
although when my students are very
strong
I give them another puzzle I say whites
and movin made in how many moves and the
last person I gave that to who solved it
he became the high school champion of
the US so he was right but Julia Shetty
your favorite yeah yes right the person
in question who I talked about earlier
they moved their King about a hundred
times in a row and they gave up they
said I guess it's a draw because if
whatever I can't move either one Wow
tough computer if white ever plays King
here or King here or King here or King
here at stalemate and if white doesn't
sacrifice one of his two pawns then
White's not going anywhere
and this sacrificing this pawn is a bad
idea so the way to win is to sacrifice
your age pawn because you're trying to
avoid stalemate and that's good way to
do it
now King h6 and King f6 both win but one
wins quicker one is beaten six and one
takes forever which move can white play
to keep the black King tied down on the
side yes King f6 is correct and the king
is trapped on the side now White has
made in two moves who could find such a
checkmate
whoo queen g3 forcing the black King to
go towards the white King and then Queen
here would be mate and queen here would
also be mate and most persons I show
this to if they have this position they
would go here and then here and then
here and here and by the time it gets 8
I would have h1 I would have fallen
asleep already really have coffee so
it's better to make the black King go
towards the white King than to chase it
with your king all the way down the
board Queen g3 is much quicker and in
fact from the starting position this is
why it's a play and made in seven and it
takes seven moves to me if you play h8
if you never sacrifice your pawn then
you will never win yesterday or two days
ago that's correct
two days ago Nakamura was playing in the
World Cup is Game two and he won a drawn
end game and the reason it was a draw is
black had to sacrifice all of her pawns
and get a similar position with bishops
but she was intent on saving one of her
pawns than he Queen because she only
wanted that pawn but he made a queen so
if she got rid of the plan then she
could have drawn because the pawn
actually hurt her and this is the same
thing sometimes pawns hurt you in the
end game because they're still meeting
your opponent or they're stopping your
king from walking in somewhere and
that's what we saw in some of the
previous examples so by getting rid of
this pawn white wins easily with the
pawn everything is stalemate ah
see sometimes I do it well other than
the mirror image on the other side of
the board which I can't stop but this is
the only position in chess where white
has a king in three pawns and none of
them are doubled and none of them are
tripled and it's White's turn to move
against a bear King and it's still a
draw right he's like what normally three
pawns beats no pawns normally but this
is actually a puzzle that I was given by
many tiny US women's champion and as at
on ski and she said set up a position
where white as the king and three pawns
black has a king it's White's turn to
move and it's a draw now if the pawns
are Donald or tripled I can do it but on
three different files that's not easy
and in fact if this pawn is on a two
this is a win for white about a three
it's a draw
hard to understand so white plays king
b2 black takes and white plays King b3
now black has seven legal moves but only
one of them drawers that's a percentage
I cave and begin to understand black to
play and draw
if you were here when the lecture
started then you said was the word you
used opposition what is it King b5 if it
was blacks move here black would be
losing but it's White's move if black
plays King c5 the obvious move now white
wins with a not so obvious move white to
play and win King a4 very good then
black takes and white keeps the black
King out and white makes a queen
however after King b5 it's White's move
and white can't wait if white plays a4
then is King can't go to a4 and black is
just in time to stop the pawn where's
Robert has to complain about that you
need to work here we understand that Jo
you didn't work here then when it
whatever house was giving a lecture and
that happened he's like somebody turned
it off so which I could do in one second
but kind of took one second they're
actually taking an hour to do
okay now Hess is happy and this is what
we call Zuke's long whoever's turn it is
to move doesn't want to move and if King
c3 then we can't play King a4 and get
behind the King there so king b5 the
only drawing move very hard to find
because you're not going towards the
pawn but you're stopping the white king
from moving up if white plays d6 to
distract and then moves his King up
black and sneak his King back just in
time and this would be a draw so even
three pawns up you're not completely
winning now if I could change the
position slightly because I made a claim
earlier that nobody believed I bet let's
put the pawn on a2 now white wins
because in this position
what's the winning move for white
a three and now it's blacks move that's
what the plot had to start on a three so
sometimes you want it to be your move
sometimes you want to be their move when
your position is perfect you don't want
to move ah okay when you were taught
chess and you were taught opening
principles
you probably heard the word Center a lot
play in the center playing the middle
take towards the center Center this
Center that and when you play in the
center and your opponent plays on the
side then you should win as you would
know from Monday Tuesday Wednesday the
chess camp so I give white to Center
pawns and I give black to side pawns
like to move what do you think should
happen here white wins black wins or
draw
all right who says why twins raise your
hand who says black wins and who says
Buchanan can't vote twice I saw that
your votes don't count actually in that
case that case you could vote after you
die yeah and after you die the dead are
voting Republican according to The
Simpsons dead pets anyway
okay so black is winning because the
class said so and because this is the
theory of the outside passed pawn so
this is the inside of the board and then
this is outside of the board there's no
board anymore when you're on the outside
of the board and you're on both outsides
of the board I don't think the white
king can stop both of those pawns
however two Center pawns that are
connected blacks King just sits right
there
so black starts moving one of his pawns
it doesn't matter which one and then
black will white will go over there and
stop it and then blacks the move the
other one and you can't
and yeah you're white black so you get a
queen and white white can move his pawns
with the black Kings right there in
front of them so so there's an easy win
for black black pushes the outside pawns
and white gives up
let's see pawn here better stop that
pawn and then here and then on our white
resigns black Queens is h-bar so
unfortunate so in a lot of end games
especially King and pawn endings but
also Knight and pawn engines which we're
not talking about you want to have
outside pass pawns on the side because
even with one outside pass pawn if
White's King is moving towards it they
can't control any other part of the
board with two outside plans and and
Knights don't like to stop outside pawns
for the night and pawn endgame white
would put is Knight here to stop the
pawn then is nice not very active so in
end games usually you want pawns on the
outside of the board not the inside in
the opening you want the inside because
you control everything and the last made
up position before my real positions
White's a play is it a win or a draw
who says white wins who says draw
yeah White's King is two squares in
front of this pawn and if it's White's
and move white just play XIII and starts
moving his King up because white has the
opposition that wins pretty handily on
the other hand if this was the position
and it was White's turn to move then it
would be a draw because wherever white
was black would follow and black would
have the opposition white plays King F
for black plays King f6 if white plays
King d4 black plays king d6 as long as
your two squares in front of the pawn it
doesn't matter whose turn it is if it's
White's turn just goes here and now it's
blacks turn and if it's blacks turn it's
even easier we just know well I can't I
can't have a B blacks turn because if
you don't let me
but White's winning and I found three of
my own King and pawn end games that were
played a while ago I think I saw you
watching this game when I was playing it
1984 were you there no my opponent
played King takes Knight good idea right
all right so it's blacks turn to move is
black winning white winning or a draw
and what should black play that's a lot
to think about
it is blacks turn to room light just
took my night but what's the evaluation
White's winning blacks winning draw who
says whites winning who says blacks
winning who says draw I'll say drive
notes wrong just with a little of each
well that depends on what move you make
if both sides play perfect I know the
result but if you make a mistake then
the another result now I heard a move
suggested that was not good and then one
of the results would be right not the
correct one King III was suggested but
that's actually a big mistake now
White's winning other White's shouldn't
have been winning but he is now White's
a play and win and we talked about this
and our other puzzles the winning method
that 'if I've right and why it's going
to make a queen so then why it's going
to win and blacks King is well placed to
stop be five blacks King is controlling
e5 so I played f5 then we traded and
well the reason black wins is black has
an outside pass pawn my pawn is over
here on the outside not near the center
that means why it's going to spend a lot
of time staying on the outside while the
black King is taking everything so after
King a3 for example I think he played g4
which is terrible but if he just tries
to win my pawn then I have two ways to
win I can just go take these pawns or I
could take this one first to be safe and
then I can go take his pawns and my
Kings taking all of his pawns and his
Kings not near my pawns so so black
would win and that's why the outside
pass pawn wins when pawns are traded one
guy's king is out of play
my opponent played g4 trying to get all
the pawns off the boy
bird but he mainly got his pawns off the
board okay and then he resigned because
I'm going to be a queen ahead right so
black was winning but actually was a
very important trick a lot of my
students suggest King III because they
want to go take all these pawns and they
don't see that a five is queening for
white so your opponent can have counter
play you have to be careful another way
to win is to play f6 this way this
prevents a5 because the F pawn can take
and now our King can run in and take all
these guys we have to take measures
against e5 make sure our pony doesn't
make a queen this was played in 1990 and
in Holland so the wrong Ben is here if
only only Ben Conover was here then then
then Conover would really die
I pushed control f2 exactly what you
wanted me to do exactly what you wanted
me to do okay so I took well we each
have four pawns on the Kings side and we
each have one pawn in the Queen side the
most important thing you can learn from
this class if that's possible that
should cover anything would you're
Malinsky say something funny so protect
your Malinsky is your saying something
funny if there's anything you can learn
it's an end games especially King upon
in games the most important thing is
King position if your King walks up the
board it is active at an end game and
your opponent's king is staying on the
first rank and not doing anything the
active King will win in the opening it's
the other way around you want your King
safe but in the end getting your king is
active here blacks King is more active
because my King can come in here and
take this pawn and make a queen
well my opponent didn't want me to do
that so he played King d2 now actually I
analyzed quite a long way ahead before I
did this because this was 1990 when I
was actually good so it was a long time
ago even you weren't at the game in 1990
and I calculated if I took all his fawns
and he took my b4 pawn we would both
queen but I would have a winning queen
and pawn endgame for a couple of reasons
but there's a very key move in this
endgame okay so I'm going to win all his
King side pawn so he wins my queen side
pawn now most people would play a floor
without thinking because you're trying
to make a queen well if you play a four
my king will go and stop you're a pawn
before you Queen and I'll have to
connected pass pawns and those will win
what move can white make so blanks King
can't get back there and stop White's
pawn loud so I can hear king c5 now my
king can't get over there so we're both
going to Queen and we did and if I could
win his Queen I would win if I could
trade Queens I would also win because I
have a passed pawn if I don't trade
Queens and it's his move he'll start
checking me and probably it's a draw but
I can trade Queens with Queen B to check
a queen F to check now if King c6 his
king and queen are lined up on the
diagonal not good for him so he played
King to b5 I checked and now he realized
I'm going to trade Queens if he goes to
the a file I'll check and take his queen
if he goes to c5 or c4 it doesn't matter
which I check he could go to b5 or b3
and I check and trade Queens and black
has a winning king upon endgame in fact
even though white lost too bad for him
but he's playing me so he found the
great move king c5 if he doesn't find
that move I won't have any problem in
all winning
I'll just defend his pawn and the two
connected passed pawns defend themselves
he could never take this one because
then this one will queen
so that would be an easy win for me but
he didn't let me do that he made us both
Queen upon so he tried and he failed
miserably the lesson is never try black
to play remember black is going down the
board and White's going up don't forget
that black to play is black winning or
it's a draw assuming both sides play
correctly I'm not sure of Isaac's hand
his razor
he's tired he's up to 1 a.m. I can't
tell doc totally confused blacks turn to
move is black winning or it's a draw
Black's winning now if these pawns
weren't here then it would be a draw as
white just runs his King in the corner
well actually I think the moves are here
I took and then I played h5 and white
has to make a move it's unfortunate he
wants to keep my King bottled up so he
played b5 and my Kings bottled up and
then I played h4 and it's his move to
bad and he has to let my king out which
is unfortunate for him so he did and I
go take his beep on and I win if it was
White's a move here and he could put his
King anywhere on the board where would
he put it anywhere what's the only good
square b3 draw King b3 opposition but I
don't think he can play King b3 if he
could then there would be a draw but he
could not and this reminds me of another
endgame which will be the last one but I
didn't put it up here because I forgot
this could have been the end of a game
that I had but to was before this he
resigned because he was strong
grandmasters so he knew what would
happen
White's a play white wins black wins or
draw
it's White's turn to move black wins
anybody else everybody agree white wins
just to be contrarian Chicago people
she's so country and she was for the
Cardinals he's from Chicago that's when
you know that that's it black wins black
wins I was white my opponent resigned
because then I give him they scared him
now White's actually winning because
White's closer by files to the pond he's
going to attack first King here and King
here ah King age five the winning move
and now when I take this pawn which I
will Black has to play King g7 not easy
to do or impossible and if you saw it
ahead and decided okay I'm going to lose
that G pawn so I'm just going to get my
I'm going to walk my King over here and
draw well you can't walk your King over
there Oh too bad can't move your King
closer and now you have to play King g7
but you can but yeah King h5 is a nice
move and this is called mutual Zook
swung or as they say in French three
Boucher it's uh both sides are in Zhuge
swung whoever's turn it is loses
hey when that happens and they have on
the opening too often or ever
but in the endgame King and pawn versus
King and pawn I could actually set up
several positions like this one where if
it's your turn to move you're losing and
the reason white was winning is White's
King was closer Firewise I'm on the
e-file he's on the D file now two files
closer now I'm attacking his pawn and
when he defends I defend my pawn
it's lucky that H file existed otherwise
I'd have been lost H file exists take
the H file off the board I'm losing
so in conclusion the good player is
always lucky right confused
exactly
you